even those who never met her
her late majesty's image is an icon for
what britain stands for as a nation
on our coins on our stamps and in
portraits around the world
her legacy will endure through the
countless people she met
the global history she witnessed and the
lives that she touched
she was loved and admired by people
across the united kingdom and across the
world
one of the reasons for that affection
was her sheer humanity
she reinvented monarchy for the modern
age
she was a champion of freedom and
democracy around the world
she was dignified but not distant she
was willing to have fun
whether on a mission with double 07
or having tea with paddington bear
she brought the monarchy into people's
lives and into people's homes
during her first televised christmas
message in 1957
she said
today we need a special kind of courage
so we can show the world that we are not
afraid of the future
we need that courage now
in an instant yesterday our lives change
forever
today we show the world that we do not
fear what lies ahead
you